our other top story tonight at 11 we are
less than 24 hours away from the raiders
preseason kickoff at allegiant stadium
and for the first time raider nation
will be inside the stadium but that
likely means parking issues again
especially for people with disabilities
orco mana joins us live from allegion
with their concerns orco
well brian and denise we've seen the
parking problems here at allegion
stadium with the garth brooks concert
and the gold cup soccer match and now
with the raiders preseason starting
people with disabilities are even more
concerned
diane resetar is a polio survivor and
often has to use this power wheelchair
until you have a disability you don't
know how hard it is to get around still
she and her husband are excited to watch
the las vegas raiders at allegiant
stadium as season ticket holders but
there's one lingering question where are
we going to park recitar was at
allegiant recently for a practice and
says there's not enough handicapped
parking she's also worried able-bodied
people will take advantage of those
spots we didn't get the hundred dollar
parking thing because
there's no guarantee
another option is getting a ride recetar
uses this lift to get out of her van but
she says the ada drop off in lot b is
too far away from the stadium it is
really stressful it
i don't know what we're going to do
michael mays who often uses a walker has
a similar concern with rideshare
services there's no
provisions
from for uber and lyft to be able to
drop off
and pick up at the entry points he wants
to see a golf cart system but according
to allegiant stadium's website staff is
not permitted to escort guests to the
parking lots that's why maze is giving
away his tickets to see guns and roses
at allegiant later this month i'm not
going to even
risk
going to the
concert resetar plans on using the rtc's
game day express shuttle which is
wheelchair accessible and though it's
not ideal she's staying optimistic
that's how it is right now it'll get
better i'm sure
now we did reach out to allegion stadium
to discuss these concerns but they have
not gotten back to us yet clark county
commissioner michael naft did tell eight
news now that this whole experience will
be a learning experience for everyone
all season long reporting live tonight
at allegiant stadium orgomana 8 news now